hello youtubers I'm joining you today to
tell you about the meeting we have in
May at the Dead Sea and Jordan mid-may
15 16 17 where we will be talking about
many of the important questions that the
Arab world is facing now one important
one I'd like your help on is to help us
discuss and to see how role models can
make a difference in the Middle East we
have one question I'd like you to answer
by uploading your videos and that is
what are the important qualities that a
leader from business from science and
from young or the young population that
the youth should have to make a
difference in the future of the Middle
East please upload your views and your
responses on that and we will take these
responses to the Dead Sea and share them
with our participants and they become
part of the discussion we have there to
get the feeling from all of you how
important do you think this subject is
please respond to our poll by saying yes
or no to the question do you think role
models are important for the future of
the Middle East thank you for your views
and your contributions I look forward to
receiving them we will take them and
discuss them and we'll come back to you
also after the meeting in May